le décès de georges marchais l'une des
figures de la politique française
portrait de l'ancien leader du parti
communiste les drapeaux sont en berne au
siège du parti nombreuses réactions dans
ce journal
la crise irakienne la maison blanche jeu
la carte de la fermeté de la lippe massy
jacques chirac se dit solidaire des
états unis inquiétudes en israël une
enquête après le double accident d'avion
au clic du midi et l'installation d'un
câble à l'origine du drame
procès papon avec le portrait croisé des
deux avocats vedettes que tout oppose
deux générations de style et de jeu
médiatique
et puis du cinéma avec george clooney le
héros de la série urgences et nicole
kidman tous deux réunis dans le
pacificateur
madame monsieur bonsoir il ne laissait
personne indifférent aux hommes de
combat homme de conviction célèbre pour
ses phrases à l'emporte-pièce et pour
son aplomb georges marchais c'était le
parti communiste français pendant un
quart de siècle
il a dominé sans relâche et sans rival
la vie politique du pc georges marchais
est mort ce matin à l'âge de 77 ans
portrait réaction nous y reviendrons
tout au long de cette première partie du
journal mais d'abord il faut qu'on
l'homme de gauche georges marchais qui a
adhéré au parti il ya 50 ans un
itinéraire contrastée jean baptiste
auprès d'amis c'est la dernière
apparition publique de georges marchais
le 3 octobre dernier
il rendait hommage à aragon aux côtés de
robert hue
son successeur à la tête du parti
communiste
georges marchais était apparu fatigué
malade bien loin de ceux qui à fait le
style marché pendant plus de 20 ans le
20 décembre 1972 georges marchais
devient secrétaire général du pcf
succédant à waldeck rochet
l'accomplissement d'un parcours entamé
en 1947 par l'adhésion au pc
l'ascension a été classique responsable
cgt de la métallurgie premiers pas
ensuite dans l'ombre de maurice thorez
accès rapide au sommet de l'appareil sa
réputation alors est celle d'un dur
pourfendeur des gauchistes en 68
orthodoxe façon alignement sur l'urgent
mais en france leur marché commence avec
l'union de la gauche et la signature
d'un programme commun en juin 72 à
l'époque l'union est un combat
elle est rompue cinq ans plus tard dans
les urnes
le déclin du pc a commencé
en 1981 candidat à la présidentielle
georges marchais n'obtient que 15 points
5 % des voix après la victoire de
françois mitterrand
quatre ministres communistes entre au
gouvernement
georges marchais lui garde l'appareil
place du colonel fabien
sogeti bon oui celui avec lesquels nous
avons préparé la victoire historique de
mai 81 et celui avec lequel j'ai discuté
pour la constitution au sein du pcf la
période marché c'est aussi celle des
frondes interne à chaque fois les
contestataires des rénovateurs hors
constructeurs sont écartés en janvier 94
georges marchais quitte le secrétariat
général du pcf
remplacé par robert est une succession
préparée de longue date mais ce soir là
après l'ovation et l'hommage
une page se tourne
le 4 novembre dernier georges marchais
pourtant retraité de la politique défend
des encore son bilan dans l'humanité né
en 1920 l'année mail de la création du
parti communiste français georges
marchais incarner une certaine idée du
pcf et une certaine pratique dans un
instant nous parlerons de la
personnalité hors du commun de georges
marchais dont les répartit très
médiatiques ont inspiré les humoristes
nous évoquerons aussi le parcours
controversée du secrétaire général du
parti
mais d'abord l'émotion dès ce matin à la
fois chez lui à champigny à paris place
du colonel fabien où les drapeaux sont
en berne et à l'hôpital lariboisière où
il est mort parce qu'elle joue c'est bon
hôpital lariboisière ce matin la
première à venir se recueillir devant la
dépouille de georges marchais est
madeleine vincent elle l'a côtoyé
pendant plus de vingt ans je les sais
très bien j'ai travaillé longtemps avec
lui à la direction du parti communiste
est évidemment comme tous les
communistes je suis vue et triste
présent également de nombreuses
personnalités dont robert hue andré
lajoinie ou encore yves mourousi
au même moment non loin de la cité
jardin à champigny les volets du
pavillon démarche est restent fermés la
banlieue rouge aussi pleure son grand
homme qu'est ce que votre santé ce matin
même beaucoup de peine et je suis venu
mettre un petit monde
ce match et a marqué la vie du parti sur
l'établi la va-vite du monde à moi je
suis droite a chopé le gauche et rien
[ __ ] tous partis pour le must
ces scènes là se passait à saint denis
les militants qui distribue l humanité
ont appris la nouvelle dans la rue mais
malgré la tristesse c'est surtout de
changement qu'il parlait ce matin c'est
avec georges marchais que nous nous
sommes débarrassés si je puis dire c'est
pas le terme qui convient mais la
dictature du prolétariat
nous l'avions du côté un peu plus tard à
villejuif le fief électoral de l'ancien
numéro un du parti
les hommages se succèdent et on pouvait
lire merci pour ce que tu as fait ou
simplement à dieu camarades
et robert hue secrétaire national du
parti s'est rendu à l'hôpital
lariboisière en fin de matinée robert
hue bouleversée par la disparition de
georges marchais en écoute je sais là la
tristesse des communistes cet homme se
dirigeant il le respectait profondément
il advenait de temps de lui même à son
parti il les a représentés si longtemps
dans la vie nationale et internationale
et puis on a été si injuste à son égard
alors même qu'il avait engagé le parti
communiste français dans la voie des
changements positifs profond qui font
aujourd'hui sa mutation au siège du
parti communiste à paris nous rejoignant
maintenant guilaine chenu le drapeau
français le drapeau rouge ont été mis en
berne dès ce matin ambiance de
recueillement pour les militants
ghislaine oui depuis 15 heures des
militants premier miss vienne salue la
mémoire de georges marchais des
registres ont été disposés à l'intérieur
place du colonel fabien pour recueillir
tous les témoignages d'autres livres
sont ouverts au siège du journal
l'humanité ainsi que dans les sections
communistes
ici le défilé est silencieux chacun
destine son hommage avec ces mots côte à
côte des militants des dirigeants et des
ministres
il a contribué et en plus dans des
conditions souvent difficiles et
délicats ou même contradictoires là il a
peu avancé avec gunter mission le parti
communiste français sans bien sûr reliés
à ses yeux ce que devait être le parti
comme le bureau national du parti
communiste a rendu cet après midi un
hommage officiel à son ancien secrétaire
général
demain le corps de georges marchais
devrait être transféré au funérarium de
bry sur marne et il sera inhumé jeudi au
cimetière de champigny merci guilaine
chenu l'itinéraire politique de georges
marchais se confond avec le parti
lui-même georges marchais homme
d'appareil fut contesté à l'intérieur
dès les années 75
il n'a pas su ou voulu prendre ses
distances avec le grand frère soviétique
georges marchais dans le passé comporte
des zones d'ombré notamment pendant les
années de l'occupation
j'évite heimberg jean yves perrin au
départ il n'y avait qu'une version
officielle sur le passé de georges
marchais envoyé en allemagne contre son
gré en 1942 mais au début des années 70
la controverse éclate lancé notamment
par d'anciens résistants s'est
volontairement affirme-t-il que le futur
secrétaire général serait aller
travailler chez le constructeur d'avions
messerschmitt c'est une calomnie que de
dire j'ai été volontaire en allemagne
j'ai été comme près d'un million de
travailleurs je crois victime du service
du travail obligatoire en 1981 pourtant
l'express relance la polémique
d'autres documents d'autres témoignages
apparaîtront jusqu'à ces dernières
années suscitant toujours la même
réaction
moi j'ai ma conscience pour moi en tant
que dirigeant c'est l'alignement de son
parti sur les régimes soviétiques qui
vaudra à georges marchais les critiques
les plus sévères pour ses détracteurs il
est l'homme de moscou où règne alors
leonid brejnev et les jugements s'en
ressentent
alors qu'en 68 le pcf avait dénoncé
l'écrasement du printemps de prague de
congrès en congrès et propos sont tout
autres lorsqu'il s'agit de tirer un
bilan dansant ont considéré le bilan des
pays socialistes
début 1980 les chars soviétiques ont
envahi l'afghanistan
georges marchais approuvé ces deux
moscou qu'il le dit en direct à la télé
manière et je vais me promener dans les
rues de moscou
et ça c'était une erreur catastrophique
par rapport à la sensibilité y compris
d'une grande partie de l'électorat
populaire communistes et çà c'est payé
ça et aussi le refus de soutenir les
syndicalistes polonais avec gorbatchev
il semblera moins à l'aise qu'avec ses
prédécesseurs le tournant de la
pérestroïka puis la chute du mur de
berlin semblait ne plus appartenir à son
histoire
lionel jospin dans un long communiqué
estime que georges marchais restera dans
l'histoire comme une figure vigoureuse
du mouvement communiste au sein de la
gauche
le premier ministre ajoute que marché
fut l'homme des transitions du parti
communiste français transition qui
l'accompagna non sans contradictions
s'il voulu et prépare à l'union de la
gauche
il fut également l'un des artisans de sa
rupture s'il fut convaincu de la
nécessité de faire évaluer la doctrine
communiste évoluer la doctrine
communiste il ne sut pourtant pas
engagées ce mouvement suffisamment tôt
fin de citation
tout au long de la journée les réactions
politiques se sont donc multipliés pour
jacques chirac
c'est une vraie figure qui s'efface à
droite comme à gauche
chacun évoque l'action et la
personnalité de georges marchais je vous
propose de les écouter on pouvait
apprécier ne pas apprécier ses
convictions en tout cas elle était
toujours sincère et est fondée sur un
engagement total
mais aujourd'hui je crois que beaucoup
de français ont en mémoire le georges
marchais humains drôle vigoureux plein
de verve et c'est vrai qu'avec lui c'est
une certaine époque de la vie politique
qui disparaît monsieur marché a beaucoup
plus freiner le mouvement de rénovation
du parti communiste qui ne l'a
accélérait et ça a été une sorte
d'originalité française en europe parce
que beaucoup de partis communistes ont
entrepris de se remettre en cause et de
remettre en cause leur erreur et une
époque on réclame volontiers des
repentances aux uns et aux autres s'il y
en a qui devrait faire cette oeuvre de
rependant se sont bien
les dirigeants communistes georges
marchais grand communicateur il sut
utiliser la télévision et les médias
mieux que personne ses coups de gueule
ses réparties son aplomb ont même
inspiré les humoristes caroline landry
ou ne manquerait pas vous ne
m'empêcherai pas devant les millions mon
objectif c'est mon objectif
il est de démontrer qui est responsable
de la crise profonde que connaît notre
pays parce que là vous ne vous pose non
non pas du tout pas là dessus maintenant
je veux parler et terroriser les médias
lui qui aimait tellement les les caméras
qui aimait tellement là la presse
audiovisuelle et qui avait apprivoisé
les télés il terrorisait les médias et
en même temps il est fasciné il est
fasciné par sa capacité à occuper toute
la scène publique et tout l'écran et en
même temps refuser les questions ne
croyez-vous pas que je que georges
marchais soit responsable du mauvais
temps qui sévit actuellement sur la plus
grande partie de la france
est ce que vous pensez être question
qu'on était friand et c'est même à force
de limites et qu'il est passé de
journaliste politique à chansonnier le
personnage l'inspirait par son accent
ses mimiques mais au delà du tribun il
admirait les talents du comédien et
quand j'ai limité marchait j'imaginais
que je le voyais à la télévision en
train de dire ce que je disais si vous
voulez donc ça fait que quand il lui
disait on ne peut pas prendre des
initiatives de cette nature j'imaginais
que je le voyais
grâce à la télé et je me prenais pour
lui les convives se régaler des soucis
discours politique georges marchais
évidemment faisait partie de l'élite les
1er j'ai rencontré d'or dans un couloir
du kremlin ils se rendaient au mausolée
ligne pour voir s'ils étaient pas il m'a
vu m'a dit bonjour du cou et m'a demandé
des nouvelles de jean jaurès
quelle image de marché l'on nous planter
7 de l'homme politique ou bien celle de
ses d'imitateur ont fait saliver
alors quelle est la question que nous
aurions pêcheurs ou les pas de questions
économiques son fils alors avec mou sur
ce plateau alain duhamel bonsoir lors de
différentes émissions et notamment en
cartes sur table avec jean pierre
elkabbach vous avez accompagné la quasi
totalité de la carrière de georges
marchais on vient de voir ensemble
quelques extraits ce que le personnage
était aussi abrupte aussi imprévisible
en direct qu'il y paraît ah oui ça
imprévisible incontestablement il
adorait la télévision il l'aimé
tellement que un jour où après une
émission extrêmement tumultueuse
je lui avais dit en sortant un petit peu
pour apaiser le climat est si vous
n'avez pas fait de la politique était
communiste qu'est ce que vous aviez
voulu faire il avait eu un cri du coeur
et il m'avait répondu présentateur du 20
heures à la télévision et on sentait que
c'était le fond de ce qu'ils croyaient
il était très doué comme comédien il est
expressif il était assez rapide
intellectuellement en même temps il
avait tout le monde le sait très bien
des scories formidable dans le langage
qui faisait rire
alors tout ça et le dé doubler parce que
en même temps il impressionnait par sa
présence physique était grande
par son talent d'expression qui était
pittoresque et puis on l'écoutait aussi
un petit peu comme une attraction voire
quelquefois comme quelque chose de
comique ce qui était en l'occurrence
inefficace puis dirait qu'il a fait
autre chose en dehors de ces dons c'est
qu'au fond il a compris que la lutte des
classes passé par les studios et que son
travail à lui c'était d'abord d'incarner
la lutte des classes dans les studios
alors elle un duel mais lequel bilan du
communiste georges marchais la chute du
moule l'éclatement de l'empiré
soviétique n'ont laissé un peu sans
repères on a l'impression qui n'a pas
été visionnaire disons que il a été
certainement plus efficace et plus
marquant à la télévision que sur le plan
idéologique ou électorale ce serait faux
de dire qu'il n'a jamais évolué bien sûr
qu'il a évolué il a évolué dans des
contradictions terrible il a évolué dans
des conditions difficiles mais quand il
a pris la tête du parti communiste le
parti communiste avait plus de 20%
d'électeurs 23.5
quand il l'a quitté il avait moins de
10%
premier échec deuxième échec c'est un
des derniers représentants de ce
prototype du communisme d'origine
prolétaires et intégrée dans un appareil
internationales auxquelles il croyait
tout à fait or le monde communiste le
monde soviétique s'est écroulé effondré
sous ses yeux
et puis je dirais que sur le plan de la
tactique politique et il n'a pas
toujours atteint ces résultats je dirais
même ce qui est peut-être pire que quand
ils les atteignait quelque fois c'était
à son détriment
juste un mot sa plus grande erreur à
votre avis sa plus grande réussite a été
la signature l'union de la gauche sa
plus grande erreur ça a été aussi la
signature l'union de la gauche parce
qu'il s'est aperçu que le parti
communiste isolés se neutraliser mais
que le parti communiste unis en réalité
était le double de l'histoire
merci alain duhamel voilà ce que l'on
pouvait dire ce soir sur la disparition
de georges marchais qui sera je vous le
rappelle enterré jeudi prochain chez lui
à champigny venons vend à l'étranger
avec la crise irakienne la maison
blanche demandent à la russie et à la
france de faire pression
moscou aurait accepté jacques chirac se
dit solidaire le point de la situation
philippe rochot le porte avions george
washington a franchi le canal de suez
avec 6000 hommes d'équipage et 77
appareils de combat dans 48 heures il
sera dans le golfe ou total une
vingtaine de navires de guerre
arriveront dans la région en début de
semaine ça n'est pas la guerre du golfe
a dit clinton mais les préparatifs lui
ressemble madeleine albright le
secrétaire d'état américain en visite
dans les pays du golfe a salué les
inspecteurs de l'onu
expulsé par bagdad le refus de l'irak de
coopérer avec les experts en désarmement
fait courir un risque inacceptable à la
région at elle dit
car l'irak peut produire des armes de
destruction massive mais à la différence
de 91 tous les pays du golfe comme
l'arabie le koweit ou les émirats freine
les états unis dans leur projet
militaire contre l'irak
la france de son côté a durci sa
position vis-à-vis
de bagdad l'attitude actuelle des
dirigeants irakiens est inacceptable il
accepte et par conséquent je la condamne
l'irak n'a pas d'autre solution que de
coopérer avec la communauté
internationale
je me suis entretenu longuement ce matin
avec le président bill clinton
je lui ai dit que la france était
solidaire de l'onu et des états unis
dans cette crise
ce matin l'avion espion eu deux appuis
effectuer sa mission au dessus du
territoire irakien sans être inquiété
alors que saddam hussein avait promis de
l'abattre
c'était un test les vols reprendront
demain en attendant les irakiens
continuent d'occuper dans la joie
apparente les sites stratégiques
susceptibles d'être bombardé par les
américains comme ici les usines textiles
de la banlieue de bagdad
la politique du bouclier humain se
perfectionne et suffit à elle seule à
désorienter la puissance militaire
américaine en chine après la visite
officielle du numéro ayant émis aux
états unis il ya quinze jours libération
aujourd'hui du plus ancien prisonnier
politique chinois en tout 18 ans de
réclusion qui suivent l'histoire
politique du pays
richard binet la signature de la liberté
celle de weining sheng le plus ancien
prisonnier politique de chine
47 ans dont 18 passés en prison en 1979
vaille à 27 ans mouse et tunga décédé
depuis trois ans leray à l'ouverture et
la contestation envahi les rues de pékin
mais le jeune va y va trop loin ils
réclament une démocratie à l'occidentale
et en république populaire cela se paye
cher 15 ans de prison pour activités
contre révolutionnaires 1989
le printemps de pékin la skin and men va
jingsheng est devenu une figure
emblématique de la contestation
estudiantine
deux mois plus tard la répression
consacrera un nouveau durcissement du
régime septembre 93 opération charme
la chine souhaite accueillir les jeux
olympiques de l'an 2000 vaille à libérer
mais l'homme est têtu il fustige à
nouveau le régime de pékin
verdict quatorze nouvelles années de
prison novembre 1997 rencontre entre
yang et minent le nouveau numéro un
chinois et le président bill clinton le
réalisme économique vous bien la
libération d'un dissident vaille s'est
envolé ce matin pour détroit aux états
unis le septième sommet de la
francophonie s'est achevée ce matin
comme prévu c'est boutros boutros ghali
l'ancien numéro un du menu qui devient
secrétaire général de la francophonie
pour les quatre ans à venir
coup de théâtre quelques heures
auparavant avec la décision pour l'ex
zaïre de quitter la francophonie le
président kabila expliquant que son pays
ne veut plus être dans la sphère de l'
influence française en france à la seyne
sur mer après deux nuits de violence le
calme semble revenu hier soir de
nouveaux échauffourées entre des jeunes
et des forces de police
une explosion de violence après la mort
d'un adolescent mardi soir dans un
accident de moto agnès vahramian et
vincent nguyen
ils étaient une centaine de jeunes et
plus du double de crs face à face en
deux nuits une dizaine de voitures ont
brûlé et plusieurs commerces de la cité
n'ont pas échappé aux jets de pierres
les incidents se sont déroulés sous les
yeux des habitants
ils sont 15 min 6 dont 40% touche le rmi
c'est la mort accidentelle d'un jeune
garçon de 18 ans qui a tout déclenché
mardi soir l'adolescent a été renversée
par un policier municipal qui n'était
pas en service depuis les jeunes de la
cité ont le sentiment que la justice
leur cache la vérité on dit il ya la loi
de la jungle et là il ya la loi de la
cité
allez savoir ce qui va se passer
personne voilà la vérité la vérité de
cet accident selon l'anc est
l'automobiliste n'est pas en cause dans
la mort du garçon qui roulait sans
casque et sans permis mais pour les
animateurs du quartier le malaise des
jeunes n'ai pas entendu le maire de la
seyne sur mer a par exemple refusé ce
week end de les recevoir
une enquête est ouverte après le double
accident d'avion qui s'est produit hier
au pic du midi faisant six victimes en
cause un câble situé à une cinquantaine
de mètres de hauteur partant du col de
sencours en direction du pit qui 1010
reportage muriel la saga et olivier
combe enquêteurs et gendarmes ont
travaillé toute la journée sur les lieux
de l'accident
trois enquêtes judiciaires
administratives et civiles sont menées
conjointement le plus urgent la
récupération de toutes les pièces
techniques susceptibles de fournir des
indices sur les paramètres du vol
une tâche difficile car il n'existe pas
de boîtes noires pour l'avion de
tourisme
en outre des milliers de débris se sont
répandus sur le versant sud du pic du
midi
on voit mal les raisons pour lesquelles
il a pu venir percuter la montagne à cet
endroit là cela dit il y a tout un
nombre de raisons qui restent à définir
l'avion était un des rares à 400 mhz
réjean nouvelle génération qui était un
agent qui était révisée à neuf moteurs
cellule donc d'un potentiel qui sortait
de région si les causes de l'accident
d'avion restent encore inconnues les
enquêteurs en revanche sont persuadés
que l'hélicoptère a bel et bien heurter
ce câble un câble de chantier installé
il y a trois mois pour l'aménagement du
pic du midi pour les hélicos c'est vrai
que c'est un handicap majeur et un
problème de sécurité permanent même en
les connaissant bien dans cette enquête
les conditions exceptionnelles
d'ensoleillement sont également prises
en compte
le pilote de l'hélicoptère notamment a
pu être aussi victime d'un éblouissement
ce week end à toulon de fête du livre
concurrentes l'une organisée par la
mairie front national et l'autre sous la
houlette du conseil général du var cette
deuxième manifestation s'est créé on
s'en souvient après le refus l'an passé
de jean-marie le chevallier de rendre
hommage à marek halter visite guidée
dans les travées de ces deux salons
vincent nguyen et jean-françois
giorgetti à ma droite la fête du
départemental du lit à ma droite aussi
mais un peu plus la fête municipale du
livre de toulon de salon de style
différent à quelques centaines de mètres
l'un de l'autre à la fête de la mairie
front national la plupart des exposants
ne cachent pas leur sympathie politique
est suffisamment et d'amitié au sein du
mouvement national pour me sentir tout à
fait chez moi je pense qu'il est bon
aujourd'hui que dans un salon
le front national puisse exprimer ses
idées c'est ça aussi la démocratie
les livres politiques comme les autres
ouvrages ont attiré les curieux et
contenter les sympathisants des années
et puis c'est une initiative sympathique
et je suis surtout satisfait du choix de
livres religieux et de spiritualité que
j'ai du mal à trouver le maire de toulon
se réjouit mais ne mâche pas ses mots
contre l'initiative concurrente du
conseil général du var 'cela fait que de
la sottise et du gaspillage des fonds
publics parce que financé à hauteur de 4
millions 5
une deuxième fête à toulon j'ai
parfaitement imbécile mais cette
deuxième fête est un succès près de
cinquante mille personnes s'y sont
pressées ce week-end
je pense que tout se passe ici donc je
viens là c'est une façon si les dire
quelque chose contre un mouvement
politique
il faut dire que la majorité des grandes
maisons d'édition ont choisi cette fête
tout comme les signatures les plus
prestigieuses il ya une foire une vraie
foire aux livres il ya une foire de gens
qui descendent de gens qui brûlent les
livres
moi j'aime pas qu'on brûle les nus les
staliniens les fascistes n'aime pas les
livrer
donc je suis dans ce salon là parce
qu'ici c'est le savons la liberté qu'à
cela ne tienne la fête du livre de la
mairie front national avait aussi son
invité de marque
maïté star culinaire venu évoquer la
bonne cuisine française on a beau dire à
bordeaux le procès papon devrait
reprendre demain malgré l'état de santé
fragile de l'accusé après six semaines
d'audience nous vous proposons ce
portrait croisé des avocats vedettes de
génération de style avec un point commun
le jeu médiatique dominique verdeilhan
et dominique merlin fait rarissime dans
un procès criminel de hauts magistrats
siège continuellement à l'audience pour
l'accusation il incarne la rigueur et la
sérénité fréquemment il jette un oeil
amusé vers l'imprévisible arno karsfeld
l'un des 30 avocats des parties civiles
qui arrivent tous les jours au palais en
roller allure décontractée chéri par les
médias mais à l'audience m klarsfeld
contrecarre fréquemment l'accusé dans
son sac il y a le dossier pape on y lit
à la mémoire de 1600 juge bordelais
bousquet touvier papon forme sa trilogie
judiciaire et la défense de maurice
papon depuis six semaines ne le surprend
pas voici une défense qui est quasi
générale sur tous les criminels contre
l'humanité s'est d'ailleurs toujours
minimisé leur rôle je n'étais qu'un
rouage n'était qu'un porte plus jeunes
étaient fonctionnaires subalternes
quelles qu'aient été leurs
responsabilités ils ont toujours cette
défense et puis l'autre de dire j'ai
j'ai sauvé des juifs fait ce qui dans le
cas de maurice papon et il faut il tenir
fonctionnaires subalternes et les juifs
qui l'a sauvée il l'a fait ou sur un
temps où sur intervention ou alors il a
simplement radiés des gens qui n'étaient
pas juives du fichier des juifs
maurice papon remis en liberté arno
klarsfeld avait quitté violemment le
procès l'espace d'un week-end 23
audience plus tard le plus important lui
semble être le changement à vue de
l'ancien fonctionnaire du maréchal
pétain il ya cinq semaines maurice papon
sortait libre de ce palais de justice
sortez libre et arrogant il est toujours
libre aujourd'hui mais il est moins
arrogant il est moins arrogant parce
qu'on rentre dans l'étude des faits on
est où il est moins arrogant parce que
ils les confronter à ses responsabilités
il deviendra de moins en un arrogant au
fil au fil des audiences
autre style autre stratégie maître jean
marc varaut comme maurice papon son
avocat est sous haute protection
constante même durant les interviews
ils refusent l'idée que depuis plusieurs
jours l'accusé soit en difficulté la
défense dit il a incontestablement
marqué des points
après la liberté maître jean marc varaut
attend l'acquittement six semaines le
procès a changé d'âme il a changé
l'aspect et ce qui était impossible est
arrivé sa liberté
on l'avait fait un manic 1 on l'avait
appelé maurice papon passe au témoin
entendu un homme tout différent qui est
apparue bras ça c'était moi et grâce aux
historiens
désormais on ne peut plus dire comme la
vigne absurdement la chambre
d'accusation qu'il connaissait la
solution finale accusé maurice papon et
escorté protéger nettement plus que
lorsqu'il fut ministre
demain il sera confronté à christiane
hippolyte ancien employé à la préfecture
de la gironde entre 42 et 44
ils seront séparés par la vitre du box
et par 55 ans d'histoire en france la
mort est un sujet tabou reste qu aux
yeux des professionnels est aussi un
commerce
la preuve entre ce week end un salon du
funéraire a ouvert ses portes avec les
dernières nouveautés que nous présente
claude crespo gens ne vous sert hommage
aux mélomanes que devait être le
locataire de ce tombeau
celui-là a sans doute été un marin c'est
ce que veut souligner cette lampe
alimenté par panneaux solaires durée de
vie limitée elle la personnalisation
c'est l'idée forts de ce salon
même à l'inter de la tombe avec les
cirques décoré de bas-reliefs au choix
16 dames d'illustration la pêche la
chasse la nature le métier du bâtiment
l'automobile le sport la montagne et il
y en a encore toute une gamme à l'étude
avec même s'il vous plaît des capitons
coordonnées ou alors on peut opter
tendance hippie pour la toile de jean
pour les amateurs de crémation de plus
en plus nombreux en france 13%
le cirque est en carton mille francs
environ du chic en vannerie pour adultes
et même pour enfants si le défunt a
exprimé le désir de voir ses cendres
enfouis dans l'océan
l'urne qui s'auto dissout en une heure
pour éviter d'être prise dans les filets
des pêcheurs
ces bijoux aussi sont des ions pour
garder sur soi un souvenir de l'être
disparu
200 exposants et côté français un marché
qui représente 15 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires l'année 98 marque une étape
importante avec le décès du monopole
communal ça va vouloir dire plus de
concurrence
donc qui veut dire plus de plus de
concurrence plus d'entreprises au
service de ce métier là donc ça veut
dire plus de professionnalisme puisque
la différence par être les meilleurs ça
veut dire plus d'innovation bien sûr et
pourtant pour cette galerie d'art
funéraire
il n'y en a pas encore assez on le sait
peu mais légalement en france il n'y a
aucun interdit en matière de sépulture
je pense que c'est rendre un très bel
hommage à un être cher disparu que
d'être capable de lui créer un monument
est de savoir ce qui lui aurait fait
plaisir et en même temps n'oublions pas
que le monument à une destinée c'est de
parler où vivent plus comme mort et si
ces morts désire tant porté outre tombe
leurs bijoux
c'est prévu sport en tennis pete sampras
n'a laissé aucune chance aujourd'hui aux
russes kafelnikov en finale des masters
à hanovre parce qu'on rate la cap 6 3 6
2 6 2 pete sampras numéro un mondial
vient d'être élu aujourd'hui meilleur
voire de sélys de ces 25 dernières
années par un jury de spécialistes
l'italie s'est qualifié hier soir pour
la coupe du monde de football nous vous
avions montré désir l'attenté des
supporteurs italiens à paris christelle
bertrand emmanuel bec ont suivi le match
en leur compagnie cette soirée de
qualification était décisive pour les
italiens mais aussi pour d'autres pays
quand le plat unique est un match de
qualification pour le mondial on préfère
dévorer l'écran des yeux et laissez la
pizza refroidir puis hier soir les
italiens de paris n'ont eu que des
émotions fortes
quand la balle trop le but russe
quand la défense italienne à des
défaillances
toute la première mi temps on s'inquiète
on se ronge les sangs ya une chose qu'on
attend
le voilà c'est casiraghi il inscrit le
but libérateur
celui ci met demi ça lui a joué sa
dixième coupe du monde david
alors forcément ça fait des supporters
heureux après un suspense pareil le but
c'est bien digéré les pattes
oui que vous allez manger des bleus il
dit
pour les belges le match face à
l'irlande est bien passé aussi sous la
pluie
les diables rouges ont marqué les
premiers les irlandais ont tout de suite
riposté et égaliser 1 but partout
mais pour les belges le principal c'est
de marquer en dernier la belgique
s'impose 2-1 et gagne sa qualification
pour la coupe du monde avec l'italie et
la belgique
la yougoslavie et la croatie sont venus
s'ajouter à la liste des qualifiés
tout comme le japon qui participera en
juin prochain
la première coupe du monde de son
histoire et l'olympique de marseille en
battant auxerre hier soir 4 à 0 au stade
vélodrome me prends la tête du
championnat de france
cela faisait quatre ans que le club
phocéen attendaient ce retour
l'olympique de marseille compte deux
points d'avancé sur le psg mais c' est
invincible depuis sept rencontres
cinéma sortie mercredi du pacificateur
avec nicole kidman et george clooney
rendu célèbre grâce à la série urgences
une sorte de james bond pour un thriller
dont le scénario pourrait se résumer
ainsi course poursuite contre un
terroriste porteur de la bombe atomique
nicolas cornu langlois prenez une star
internationale irrésistible ajouter une
bonne dose de charme et de muscles avec
une autre star infaillible compléter
avec l'efficacité de la réalisatrice qui
l'a rendu célèbre dans la série urgences
fait exploser le tout dans un
affrontement nucléaire en europe de
l'est
la nouvelle compagnie dreamworks a joué
la sécurité pour sa première production
les premières projections indiquent que
les retombées nucléaires affecteront
toutes
ce n'était pas un accident
c'est un acte terroriste il me faut nos
fils y ait des liaisons venant des
services secrets avaient des contacts
chaleureux et intime est bon qu'il
accepte les ordres d'une femme lieu d'en
coller les tops de veau aux rapports
elle selon beaux-arts tournée moderne
et vous savez une femme dans son travail
au service du gouvernement
elle lui dit écoute il faut respecter
les règles c'est comme ça et pas
question de transgresser la loi
pour moi c'est elle qui parle le langage
de la raison c'est à dire n'utilisez pas
la violence a priori y réfléchissez
avant fait son boulot et j'aime le type
comme si la donne moi je ne respecte pas
les règles du jeu moi aussi bon que la
plupart des gens qui réussissent
régis de cette façon mais que ce soit
dans les affaires ou ailleurs j'aime
aussi le fait qu'il soit fidèle à ses
amis pour moi c'est important
ces rapports humains sont le vrai pivot
de ce suspense planétaire plus que la
banane menace nucléaire au croyez qu'ils
nous acquérons qu'est votre ami pourquoi
une position parce que c'est mon ami
il faut plus de frais de ce nouveau dieu
au sauveur de l'humanité fonctionne
admirablement avec en prime à nuire plus
explosif que cette classique course
contre la montre
avant de refermer ce journal hommage au
comédien jean-marie proslier qui est
décédé hier à l'hôpital d'evreux à la
suite d'un malaise cardiaque
chansonnier artistes souvent commis que
sur scène et à la télévision
jean-marie poêlier mais également
écrivain il avait obtenu le prix
alphonse allais en 85 la valeureuse
juliette pas et sont sauvés par sa balle
ronde être une voleuse ainsi se termine
ce journal je vous en rappelle les
principaux titres le décès de georges
marchais l'une des figures de la
politique française portrait de l'ancien
leader du parti communiste
les drapeaux sont en berne au siège du
parti
la crise irakienne la maison blanche
joue la carte de la fermeté de la
diplomatie jacques chirac se dit
solidaire des états unis inquiétudes en
israël
l'enquète après le double accident
d'avion au pic du midi l'installation
d'un câble à l'origine du drame
la météo dans quelques instants laurent
romejko du soleil pour demain dernière
édition zéro heure vingt bruno roger
petit de master dans les 4 vérités
française lasbordes ii reçoit martine
bouillon à magistrat qui défend la cause
des enfants 13 heures patrick chêne
antoine cormery demain soir vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
je